teenage pregnancy like actually bad for
kids it's just the way the like teenage
moms definitely base a lot more
financial problems than mothers who
understood childbearing like there's a
penalty to early motherhood in terms of
Education in the labor market but the
effect of adolescent Parenthood on kids
particularly they're like cognitive
problems in ADHD is a lot smaller than
people might anticipate and that's
because people do not have children as
teenagers at random so like more
impulsive sensation seeking moms are
more likely to have kids young and
they're more likely to have impulsive
Sensations seeking kids there's eight
million parenting books which are all
like here are all the things correlated
with me like a high income white lady
basically is what they're all saying and
very few of those things are shown to
actually have like a causal impact on
child development